[Music]
they're trying to run it right into the
election and if that's their strategy
the American people really have to learn
that I mean that they're trying to do a
same thing Comey did they're trying to
become judge and jury of the 2018
elections that is a tragedy with a phony
investigation like this they simply
don't have any evidence of collusion and
they have no evidence of obstruction
other than their version of the truth
that was the attorney for president Rudy
Giuliani weighing in on this never
ending Muller probe meanwhile earlier
today Fox News contributor former
assistant United States Attorney for the
Southern District of New York Andy
McCarthy put out this incredible piece
Robert Muller shouldn't even ask Trump
for an interview he joins us now along
with the author of the bestseller the
case against impeaching Trump which I am
a very fond of this book along with
judge P Rose book end and Greg Jarrett's
book the three of them are all worth a
great read Harvard Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz good to see you both let me
begin with you Andy McCarthy on your
piece if the lawyer gives them 30 hours
the White House Counsel the president
goes in remember George papadopolis
Lieutenant General Flynn lying and the
FBI didn't think that Flynn was lying
Papadopoulos is basically a non-player
kid in all this why would the president
think anything but a perjury trap awaits
him Sean I think that that's obviously
what the problem is for him here we have
a history of this investigation where
you know one person remembers something
one way somebody else remembers at at
different ways the same thing happened
with general Flynn you know first they
decide he's telling the truth
then they decide that he's not 30 hours
of conversation about what the president
was saying and what he was thinking in
connection with the very actions that
Muller is looking into if the president
were to go in and submit to an interview
if he remembers anything differently
from the way that his attorney remembers
it through the White House Counsel that
may have a conflict and as I've tried to
point out those who say that
innocent person doesn't have anything to
worry about or an honest person doesn't
have anything to worry about speaking to
a prosecutor are nuts because it's the
prosecutor not the honest person yeah
who decides whether you're being honest
and I mean let's be clear when Rudy said
this weekend and I would argue it's
inarticulate you know the the truth is
not the truth what he did what he was
clearly saying was I would argue legal
jargon as a former prosecutor he knows
well that you're gonna have say Tom
McGann has one story the president says
one thing that's different the person
that will decide what is the truth will
be the special counsel that we all know
is predisposed against Donald Trump so
that is that is clear as day what he
meant in articulate but he's right yeah
that's the point he's trying to make
it's the prosecutor who's the arbiter of
the truth and that doesn't mean the
prosecutor is right it just means that's
the way the system is set up yeah
and professor Dershowitz I gotta get you
to weigh in here this is a this is
really why would it why would the white
House Counsel ever give them 30 hours
mm-hmm well I think he the originally
the original plan of the Trump defense
team was to cooperate in the hope that
the investigation would quickly end that
hope has been dashed but going back to
Rudy Giuliani for a second I have an
article on gatestone today which I say
when the truth isn't the truth making
exactly the same point that Andy made a
point that I've been making now for
three months that in order to fall into
a perjury trap all you need is one
witness who contradicts one statement
bingo that the person says to the
prosecutor that witness can be somebody
who is singing composing who has flipped
who has a deal who's been told either
you're gonna die in prison or you're
gonna tell us what we want to hear and
any defense lawyer who would ever walk a
client into a perjury trap under those
circumstances this is cybers license
reconsidered let me ask you a question I
was asking Greg earlier professor and
that is this what Paul might afford be
being prosecuted now but for all this on
a nothing to do with Russia no
collusion nothing to do with Trump
doesn't know what the campaign then the
same goes for general Flynn then the
same goes for Papadopoulos and the same
really goes for Michael Kohn isn't that
true that this is selective prosecution
or what you call the criminalization of
political differences well you don't
have to ask me that question asked judge
Ellis who's presiding over the mana for
case he has stated publicly that the
special counsel is not interested in
mana fors alleged crimes they're only
interested in squeezing him in order to
get him to flip and to either sing or
compose those words used by judge Ellis
against the president the same thing is
Coen medallions what his medallions have
to do nothing with the scope of the
special investigation now they're
investigating him in the Southern
District of New York but they're clearly
cooperating but Montes essence because
of all of this right these people Rudy's
work there and II will give you the last
word I'm really beginning to have the
more problems than I ever thought with
our criminal justice system a guy that's
facing a hundred years key witness in
the matter for case really sounds like
former bribery to me mm-hmm
yeah well look John I I think part of
the reason that the jury may be having
trouble with the case is the way it was
teed up for them Muller makes a deal
with gates who basically gets a walk for
the same conduct disguise Manta Ford may
spend the rest of his life in jail on
you guys are both done French
conservatives are finally seeing the
light about this that conservatives are
finally being credible of the justices
in something right I was wrong